[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du statut de culture le magazine
pour vous informer des actualités
culturelles du département voici le
sommaire cette année marque le
centenaire de la naissance de georges
brassens à cette occasion un camp c'est
un concert organisé par l'association
écrire à versailles sera proposée samedi
6 novembre dans le bar salle de
spectacle versailles et le ravin bleus
c'est la deuxième édition de l'opération
sauvons nos monuments dans les yvelines
deux édifices ont été sélectionnés un
seul aura la chance de bénéficier d'une
campagne de financement participatif
compte les points forts de chacun dans
cette émission et puis enfin le
spectacle des dalles sera en
représentation mardi 9 et mercredi 10
novembre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la metteur en scène marion pellissier
est en résidence nous avons filmé
répétition
georges brassens à est né le 22 octobre
l'artiste avec une partie de sa vie à
crêpière dans les yvelines à l'occasion
du centenaire de ce grand auteur
compositeur interprète français
l'association écrire à versailles
propose un concert samedi 6 novembre
regardez
c'est au ravin bleus bars et salles de
concerts à versailles que se tiendra une
soirée en l'honneur de georges brassens
samedi 6 novembre 2021 marque le
centenaire de sa naissance l'association
écrire à versailles qui regroupe des
écrivains locaux organisé un concours
pour mettre en avant les textes de
georges brassens les participants sur un
air de l'artiste devait écrire de
nouveaux textes onu 80 participants et
on a été étonné par la qualité des
enfin des réponses que nous que nous
avons reçues bassens disait que faire
une chanson c'est
c'est simple et compliqué il faut mettre
quelques mots les bons mots sur les
bonnes notes les lauréats vont êtres
vont pouvoir
se présenter chanter après il y à un
concert un chanteur yvelinois viendra
interpréter aussi les chansons peu
connues de charges croissance il ya des
tas de
deux chansons
tout à fait admirable qui m est connu
que je n'interpréterais pas je préfère
les chenilles est petit sept petites
perles méconnues comme la comme le
verger du roi louis ou
rose la bouteille et la poignée de main
qui ne passe pas souvent radio et je
trouve que c'est dommage auteur
compositeur et interprète georges
brassens a vécu de 1958 à 1971 dans les
yvelines il a habité au moulin de la
bombe au bord du ru de galli a créé
pierre ces mêmes cet endroit qui lui a
inspiré la chanson auprès de mon arbre
après deux mandats
vivait heureux dé par l'incroyable et
des mélodies absolument fantastique il
est totalement méconnu mais comme me le
dise que musicien était vraiment très
fort et franchement il ya une
plénitude à
l'interpréter que je retrouve avec aucun
autre
chanteur c'est d'écrire des paroles
depuis évolué plus jeunes années et
c'est vrai que c'est pour moi l'exemple
absolu la référence total
le maître georges brassens a mises en
musique plus d'une centaine de textes
écrits il a sorti 14 albums studio de
1952 à 1976
[Musique]
samedi 13 novembre à 20h30 le chanteur
rambolitains fab m sera en concert au
bar orge et houblon à rambouillet il
présentera son nouvel album vers un
autre matin sorti l'année dernière on
écoute une version revisitée de son
dernier titre meilleur espoir féminin
[Musique]
et d'autres concerts sont à découvrir
dans les yvelines et l'on commence par
le rotary club de rambouillet qui
propose la ville le concert espoirs en
musique à l'église de saint lubin de
rambouillet dimanche 14 novembre à 18
heures cet événement est organisé au
profit de la recherche sur les cancers
de l'enfant les dons seront versés à
l'institut gustave roussy centre de
lutte contre le cancer
debout sur le zinc enflammera la scène
de la salle de spectacle le sax à
achères mercredi 17 novembre à 20h30 le
groupe de musique aux influences rock
oriental et y gagnent présentera son
nouvel album l'importance de l'hiver
[Musique]
la malice family revient avec un nouvel
opus belle comme ta mère au con comme
ton père est sorti dimanche et 17
octobre sur les différentes plateformes
musicales ce groupe de musique a tourné
un clip à andrésy leur ville de
résidence depuis une semaine il est
disponible sur youtube on écoute la
malice family suivi d'un extrait du clip
en gros ça parle de derry dit et
l'égalité des chances un côté hérédité
c'est vrai que ces genres de deux thèmes
qui nous plaît bien ce qu'on allait sur
le premier single en acier paraît un
petit peu de deux un peu de nous un
petit peu de famille un petit peu tout
ça sans dire que ça va être le seul
thème qu'on aborde dans nos chansons on
prépare à noter que on espère sortir au
printemps 2022 donc c'est effectivement
annonciateur d'un nouvel ep sera bien
comme sa mère quand comme mon père
sincèrement que ce soit contre
[Musique]
univers cette année c'est la deuxième
édition de l'opération sauvons nos
monuments pour contribuer à la
sauvegarde du patrimoine d'ile-de-france
et d'oise le journal le parisien la
start-up d'artagnan et la région ile de
france ont déjà sélectionné 18 projets
parmi lesquels neuf bénéficieront d'une
campagne de financement participatif
il y en aura un par département céline
charles bonsoir soir célia alors dans
les yvelines les internautes devront
choisir entre deux la restauration de
l'église de mézières sur seine et celle
de l'orgue de saint béat high poly et
oui en effet sont deux à vouloir gagner
ce financement en yvelines il n'y a que
quelques kilomètres qui les séparent
mais ils ont chacun leur personnalité
bien distinctes donc le premier candidat
c'est l'orgue de l'église saint béat à
epône ce superbe instrument il nous
vient du facteur d'orgue cavaillé coll
qui date de 1878 même s'il n'a était
arrivé à epône qu en 1901 il dispose de
340 de tuyaux qui repose sur un sommier
et cet orgue il est encore utilisé tous
les dimanches pour les offices alors
quand je suis rentré j'ai été accueilli
par cette petite musique enivrante et
c'est le maire adjoint à la culture
pascal dagory qui nous en parle
oh
tout à l'heure on a fait l'expérience de
rentrer dans l'église avec le commande
avec l'orgue qui jouer fortement et on a
pu sentir
palper la musique qui nous tombait
dessus qui nous enveloppait comme un
manteau qui qui faisait que
c'est tout de suite solennelle s'est
tout de suite parce qu'on a une très
belle église qui a une très belle très
belle acoustique mais cet orgue à
quelques problèmes sincérité et oui en
effet c'est le sommier qui tire de
l'oeil en fait en cause les différentes
canicule qu'ils endommagent pour
l'instant ça s'entend pas encore
vraiment ça pourrait devenir vraiment
catastrophiques si ça devait continuer
la municipalité a jugé le coût des
travaux à 15000 euros le maire nous
expliquent ces travaux qui devraient
durer huit mois oui il faut démonter
tous les tous les tuyaux les emmener en
atelier emmené le sommier un atelier
aurait atteint des loyers tout ça mais
refaire le sommier comme il faut il ya
un temps de ces sages qui est quand même
relativement important et rien deuxième
candidat eh oui le deuxième candidat
c'est l'église saint nicolas à mézières
sur seine c'est une église qui date du
xiiie siècle dont la voûte en bois
étaient financés par françois 1er elle
possède une statue de la vierge à
l'enfant polychrome qui est classé et
une peinture originale d'une confrérie
de charité alors elle est classée au
titre des monuments historiques depuis
le maire de la ville franck fontaine va
nous en parler il met tout aussi
important que de restaurer cette église
qui est le bien culturel le plus ancien
sur notre commune ça reste du patrimoine
c'est à partir d'un historique ça n'a
pas très loin de en effet parfois
cultuelle mais c'est la pierre c'est
notre pierse et c'est ce qui fait aussi
eu quand on passe dans la rue nationale
qui est la rue commerçante bas on voit
cet édifice qui date du moyen âge et
sepa sepa 9 et cette église a besoin
aussi besoin de ce financement en
témoigne par exemple salpêtre c'est une
sorte de petite poudre blanchâtre qui
s'attaque aux enduits des murs les
statuts est la chair par exemple qui
nécessite également un petit ravalement
de façade le manque de chauffage qui
oblige l'église à être fermé en hiver ou
encore les vitraux qui nécessite un
petit petite remise en valeur ses deux
larges travaux qui se feront palier par
palier dont phase par phase le premier
nécessite dix mille euros on écoute
monsieur le maire
les autres anges
dix mille euros c'est pour les désordres
techniques en matière de 15000 euros
donc c'est une rotule est signé on
restaure la chaire partir de vingt mille
euros restaure le le le grand tableau
qui fait près de trente trois mètres de
long sur la scène d'enterrement avec la
confrérie de charité et il ya encore
bien des palais à atteindre voilà donc
vous avez jusqu'au 7 novembre le
dimanche 7 novembre pour choisir entre
les deux monuments et c'est sur le site
souvent nos monuments point fr les sites
s'affiche en bas de l'écran mais alors
que fait lille charles pour toutes les
explications je vous propose maintenant
de découvrir des dalles ce spectacle à
l'univers sombre créé par marion
pellissier est en résidence au théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il sera en représentation le 9 et 10
novembre prochains et revisite un mythe
antique le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et patrick d'actes dixit en gros
cadre flou et avancent le plus comme si
les pauvres voilà suspendu possible
pour une très lente avancée cherche pas
à faire baisser le yen
dernière répétition pour des dalles au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce
thriller à l'univers sombre et sorti
tout droit de l'imagination de marion
pellissier comme son nom l'indiqué ce
huis clos mentale revisite un mythe
antique moi j'aime bien travailler
avec des univers étrange
inquiétant mais qui propose une
métaphore possible ou une lecture une
autre lecture possible que le concret à
qui propose donc là c'est c'est que des
grilles des barreaux
vert métallique avec des parois de
grillage qui représente le dédale pour
créer ce spectacle de deux heures six
acteurs une équipe technique participent
à cette création sur deux semaines
ensemble ils ont imaginé ce labyrinthe
souvent tu peux rester à regarder on en
même les la moitié du monde la porter à
partir du manioc de dire de se barrer
lui donc je suis entendu j'ai
moi même je pars pas en
avoir j'ai pas toujours mais pas
toujours les mots sur les choses et
j'aime bien être déplacé dans dans ce
que je projette donc je quand j'ai une
idée claire mais j'aime bien que cette
idée claire elle évolue avec l'équipe
avec laquelle je travaille en tant que
comédien le le plaisir qu'on éprouve
déjà c'est de la recherche recherche
autour de la matière textuelle du sujet
des différentes figures que chacun des
comédiens comédiennes les spectacles
interprétés donc tente de développer une
atmosphère atypique à découvrir le mardi
9 et mercredi 10 novembre à 20h30 sur la
scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec un seul
mot d'ordre laisser libre cours à son
imagination
et c'est la fin de cette fuite culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine bonne soirée sur
télé 70
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]